[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
domination et de l'espoir
kembs et le jeu aussi piquant qu'une
boîte de hot wings à tel point qu'une
célèbre chaîne de restauration rapide
envisagerait même de se faire rebaptiser
kaki qui fraudent shekels il lui faut
deux équipes comme d'habitude je
commençais pour la nuit pas franck est
sauvé
donc je dirais non sur corner mais milan
et les gens savent l'éventail brin
savent les jaloux vont maigrir
l'hommage est l'homme qui rit à tout
mais van aken je ne sais faire partie de
la famille mais dès 12 ans elle a mis
fin à mes amis sachez que cette saison
là il ya deux invités où on est la
famille mais qui rend dessous tout le
monde sait michou et ils essaient de
vous tout bon back again étonnantes
comme des groupes pour emporter le cam
se dore cette année on a un cador être
qu'on peut avoir un plan sur le cap
soudeur ou abb superplan la regarde la
main film la marque peut-être en gt1
ralenti un bruit alors qu'ils se jouent
aucun ne s'est pas jouée au keynes
bah moi ça n'est pas trop joueur en
devenir est paré ont joué dans la loge
vous êtes jeu mais vous avez dû se vit
se vit se vident le verlan si c'est un
truc de vieux en fait t'as employés le
verlan d'un mort un gars
est-ce que s'il vous plaît avant de
démarrer quoi que ce soit mon petit tu
t'en levé un tabou joue bien qu'assez
tard don qui est vraiment bien passé ok
on remet le point c'est bon pour jouer
au caire il ya des règles oui vous vous
les connaissez mais les gens peut-être
les connaissent pas chez thales je suis
tranquille et aime à les gens qui les
voit chez emi nous avons quatre joueurs
les deux équipes
je vous distribue les cartes j'en ai
talent 4 milieu de la table et à mon top
vous devez échanger vos cartes avec
celles disposées sur le tapis de jeu
dans le but de réunir 4 cartes
identiques et de le faire savoir à votre
coéquipier sans vous faire choper par
les adversaires
comment le faire savoir à votre équipier
en lui faisant le signe secret sur
lequel vous serez mis d'accord ce
dernier cri alors qu'elle est l'équipe
marque un point mais attention si le
joueur adverse pensent avoir découvert
votre sim secret ils sûrs contre calais
si c'est vrai c'est lui qui marque un
point et le jeu reprend le match se joue
en trois parties mais qu'il marquant le
plus de points accède à la grande finale
buckles a dit
[ __ ] c'est bien que des règles
explique avec deux surtout parce que
chez des yeux qui connaissent rien donc
vous on s'en fout de ces règles là c'est
moi le patron puis adouci avec moi plus
je donne des points
plus vous êtes méchant moi vous avez
deux points ah oui la corde à tricher
tous vos exams est ce que je peux
demander s'il vous plaît un riverain
tout de suite pourquoi pour la veste
qu'il a colorié lui même monsieur
écoutez moi bien on doit mettre un point
tout de suite à michou et inox contre
leur flagornerie de merde et sa veste
est magnifique on t'a dit flagorneurs
ayant la gournerie la gournerie ça veut
dire quand tu bouffonne vraiment plein
de hockey ce n'est pas sérieux j'arrête
les mots compliqués en revanche on lance
la première partie pour cette première
partie et mes amis
ils avaient convenu d'un signe dans
laquelle room incident en cachette sauf
qu'on a tout filmé et on va voir tout de
suite le premier signe que vous avez
choisi de la cie si c'est vrai non non
non mais on va falloir vous y a que la
france entière tu sais cette émission
fait 75 millions de téléspectateurs en
france en france est alors monté l'année
68 ans on est 60 millions +15 mailhiot
d'arabes aller au delà pour la première
partie de kembs
est-ce que vous avez mis au point un
premier signe
ouais premiers signes vient enfin un
truc tranquille rond on s'abonne à
luanda ont fait ça tranquille petite
tape auteurs jouent quel est votre
premier signe que vous avez mis au
préalablement d'accord de vous d'accord
il s'agit d'un mot quel est ce mot till
the be the bay qui veut dire mouche
[Rires]
[Musique]
les white elles mêmes alors pour jouer
aux cartes il nous faut des cartes
remarque je ne reviendrai plus jamais
sauf si j'ai un point de plus ouais bon
allez mettez un point ferait bien d'y
ajouter un point ou bien on est bien
pour jouer au caire avait l'habitude de
jouer trois dames ballet as ce qui
risque d'être un peu chiant donc on a
remplacé les rois dames valets aspar des
cartes où on a mis des petits gags nous
mêmes nous allons jouer avec les
concours les plus débiles du monde
parmi ces concours bizarre un seul
n'existe pas celui qui me dit lequel
n'existe pas prend 1.11 averti aller le
premier concours le championnat du monde
leur taille de faire le bras de fer avec
des gros orteil s'étendant de tenir le
deuxième le concours de cheveux je les
faire la plus belle coiffure par moins
30 au canada sirieix garder un furet le
plus longtemps dans son pantalon grand
prix de chaise de bureau course de
fauteuil à roulettes vasson formule 1
elle est trop bien concours de lancers
de machine à laver le lancer la plus
loin possible et les cartes postales
challenge
moi j'ai le maximum de cartes postales
en un minimum de temps c'est pas 4e exil
qu'elle n'existe pas le quatrième exige
déjà fait le 4e 3e et l'existence
le premier qui me dit lequel n'existe
pas prend un point c'est bien la carte
postale
t as a constamment mais ça existe
garder un animal dans le snop mais je
vous jure c'est des pourris agression
envers animal ouais mais c'est des
animaux qui aime bien être dans les
slops mais nous allons jouer aussi avec
une deuxième série de cartes ce sont les
six premières cartes
la deuxième série de cartes mes amis on
va jouer au point commun je vais vous
donner cymru il ya un point commun de
ces six mois le premier qui me donne
deux points communs il a gagné un
million d'heures
on est prêt et non un point commun entre
vifs fayat tschopp doudou claqué quoi
quel est le point commun de tous ça
cartoon nom omar sy non d'argent non
chanteuse à la camorra way to die a fait
un point précis
au revoir à jour 13 août un point
résultat voilà je vais vous distribuez
dégâts quatre cartes à chacun le premier
qui a quatre cartes identiques fait le
signe à son coéquipier afin de lui
signifier qu'il a quatre quartiers de la
triche et la triche est autorisée tu
fais ce que tu veux mon frère bienvenue
au caire on est prêt kembs roja d'or
c'est parti et nerveux oui c'est parti
qui a quatre cartes pendant par la clim
tellement il ya de la tension frère
rappelez vous de vos cils regardez vous
êtes à changer comme ça parce que j'en
ai doute pour toi mon frère regarde
regarde et vous surveillez vous rappelez
vous de vos signes qui a quatre cartes
stop
est ce qu'on peut faire une pause est ce
qu'on peut ramener la caméra pour
regarder vite fait les est ce qu'on a
comme jeu s'il ya beaucoup de rigueur on
ne touche pas aux jeunes chevaux tu me
touches des pétards merci tu te regarder
vos jeux rien du tout est tranquille
être tranquille riches laisse nous
tranquilles et hockey regardez-vous
attention il ya plein de sa vie ce vice
je l'avais cette foire hausse et une
partie tellement tendue
[Applaudissements]
ce qui nous fait donc un poids plus le
chemin pour enough m us ou là pour
l'instant mais je crois - tremblay va
devoir déposer mon frère non non c'est
celle-là passe écoutez là il ya des gens
qui me disent super on joue au caire
mais bon j'ai des gens qui sont nos
invités vraiment voudrait les connaître
mieux pour ça j'ai un chrono quiz le
chrono quiz je vais vous poser une série
de quinze questions à chaque équipe
l'un après l'autre d'abord on va
commencer par michaud inox mes préférés
et amis l'équipe qui a le plus de
réponses crédibles qui sont censés vous
allez comprendre aura gagné vous êtes
prêts je vais vous enchaînez
commenge par watt il dit pas forcément
la vérité juste sans ces succès sont ses
tanks csd réponse sensée aux pièces un
concours de sensibilité série tessin
autant de chance et bon bref on est
prêts chrono près regard de wham
il ya quoi dans ta poche maintenant un
téléphone y'a quoi dans ta tête
maintenant rien il à quoi doit-on faune
tél chat il ya quoi dans ton panthéon un
grand homme niño niña
oui j'adore ces [ __ ] il ya quoi ton cv
une fois non mais qu'est-ce que j'en ai
pas de casque toutefois d'autres
produits en ce moment lignot ya qua non
à son casier judiciaire
rien ouais y'a quoi dans ton
porte-monnaie à quelque chose ma carte
bleue ma carte vitale ma carte
d'identité
ma carte fitness jacques ouest on rêve
le plus fou te caresser un éléphant on a
combien de réponses chance et l'a9
bonnes réponses ok et on continue et
maintenant nous allons passer à la
deuxième partie de kembs
[Applaudissements]
5e 2e partie de saison va jouer au
hockey mais il nous faut des signaux
secret cette fois des signaux et à
changer vous avez fait des signes au
préalable dans la came stroum dessine
que nous allons voir maintenant oui
pourquoi pas bien sûr c'est pour lassina
leur deuxième but sera super super alors
plusieurs milieux quoi votre signature
on va se présenter on va dire oui on ne
s'est pas trop jouer pour lequel on
connaît pas trop que et on va dire on va
dire qu'elle va dire contre camille et
ça ça veut dire que vous avez le comme
ça ça veut dire 15 et on va dire contre
cam ils vont rigoler vont dire un
mondial et qu'ont-ils sa page d'accueil
[Applaudissements]
pour cette 2ème on va dégager les cadets
concours débile vous savez je t'ai de
trucs et tout ça ça on les dégage
on va les remplacer avec les génies
méconnus à qui il faut rendre hommage
car ils ont changé notre vie vous allez
comprendre
parmi ces créateurs de génie vous me
dites lequel n'a pas existé points bonus
sachant que c'est tendu en ce moment le
premier nous avons marre m el kun et
kadir norman les inventeurs du kebab en
1971 était svn paris sa lors ensuite
vous avons glem burke l'inventeur du
high five en 77 jeux rien à inventer sa
vache à lait pas non mais c'est pas ça
veut pas nos poules hausse l'inventeur
de la pizza hawaïenne beau fils de [ __ ]
au nom sonne l'inventeur du pierre
feuille ciseaux ces housses qu'on se
souvienne de lui qu'il inventait
ascquois raphaël et exposito l'inventeur
de la pizza livrée à domicile en 1889
depuis 1889
on peut faire livrer des plats ses
racines grâce à lui et marcel eisenberg
l'inventeur du marcel en 1860
un seul de ses inventeurs et fo lequel
le bien failli saison en [ __ ] mais
comme le disait si tu es regard assez
noir et blanc il est parti samedi et ce
qu'ils sont en train de contester ton
jeu là oui c'est vrai qu'il n'existe pas
donc le point bonus est pour forcément
monsieur hakim gemini vous distribuez
c'est parti pour la deuxième partie de
câbles dégâts j'adore faire ça c'est
presque là tu te moques de moi c'est lui
que je pense de moi je n'avais pas non
non ça disait quoi pour lui que pour ça
vous rigoler parce qu'il n'a pas de
barbe en ce moment mais si sa cousine
ouais c'est vrai ça viendra un jour
inch'allah alors je vais vous donner
quatre cartes chacun mes amis et moi
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai trois tiens ça passe ça on est
prêt il ya quatre cartes identiques le
dit à son pote élu fellow thinks poule à
j'aime j'aime j'aime j'aime j'aime
j'aime route ça marche pas tu me
regardes il veut notre rôle et il fait
des possibles aller shooter deux parties
il te thema de ouf trop bas qui regarde
et lui il s'enfonça ivans ajouts comme
vous les gens même les gens chez vous je
ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont en eux je
regarde juste leur tête
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe mais je
sais que l'insigne va sortir c'est tendu
qui a quatre cartes identiques foppadia
[Applaudissements]
de toute façon il a bien quatre cartes
identiques et donc il a le kent ce
qu'elle est il signe super tu as 10
super ça nous fait donc un point pour
l'équipe d'accueil et du roi david
[Musique]
il reste une partie reste une partie je
vous explique les gars arrête n'ai pas
peur d'eux je vous explique
il ya on a 5 à 3 vous avez deux points
de retard c'est la dernière partie vous
pouvez lesquels commence par exemple 11
ans 1 contre keynes en faisant un double
cadeau à l'homme si tu les grilles les
bains ils avaient qu'à écouter la règle
après avant et puis il va y avoir il va
y avoir de quoi est-il
il a déjà entendu les règles dans la foi
enfin cette maladie casse les couilles
lui oui a dit le mot casse les couilles
non c'est lui qui a fait lundi un jardin
du 8 au 10 juillet pendant ce temps des
cerises je n'ai pas entendu il est temps
de faire le chrono quiz le chrono puis
c'est le truc que j'ai fait ça comme ça
oui c'était pas ouf comme sa muse et la
bonne humeur
oui bon il ya un mois vas-y non mais
qu'est ce tu es devant moi puis si tu
admires film que tu as adoré je te même
nom et 103 arnas 3 2 films et un
deuxième parce que tu sais que la série
h alors monsieur le rat points metalor à
point
non on est à 4 4 tu vois ton attitude de
keira sert à rien j'adore ces règles
voit c'est mes cartes que je les halls
quiz aller à l'essai moi j'ai lâché je
suis là par sympathie déjà c'est ça
devrait aller le chronomètre est parti
mais je répète qu'il ya eu comme un de
réponse bonne pour inox et mishka 999.9
franck gastambide ya quoi dans ton frigo
du port j'y vois dans son lit attendent
une réponse sensée c'est une réponse
juste normal ou réponse avec rires la
tannerie
merci ok ok je dois faire la une sur du
coup alors oui attention on reprend
attention frankia coin dans ta
bibliothèque dès dvd
y'a quoi dans son garage des vélos il a
quoi dont on à venir
de l'argent il ya quoi dans tes mains
la france
hier et on attend toi dans ton slip
équipe doit pas dire un truc dégueulasse
ya quamissa championnat de mes courses
y'a quoi dans ton cerveau
l'africanité ya quoi dont il ya quoi
dans tes amis qu'elle pourquoi tu seul
il ya quoi ton âge tu as des photos oui
il ya qua none to rétroviseur mes
ennemis
[Musique]
et en plus mon frère nous avons aux
bonnes réponses par rapport aux 9 de
julio et dilma a fait un point pour
franck gastambide jacqueline chez moi
franchement la croix dans son rétro elle
était pas mal et sa manie jal est belle
on passe à la troisième et dernière
partie aux dernières parties bien
entendu cette fois les filets secret
c'est moi qui vais imposer c'est moi qui
vais apprécier le troisième signe sera
quand je pense qu'on n'a pas gagné
l'eurovision depuis marie myriam
votre troisième signe il faut que vous
placiez le mot un très sec donc d'accord
même si on sait pas ce que ça veut dire
la sec m on est prêt il s'est bien fait
car et l'es6 il était super mais si vous
êtes un super super c'est cette émission
pas sur gulli pas surfer rosa dna partie
on va dégager les chansons d'ailleurs
nakamura savait où la doua et on va
jouer avec le jeu du point commun je
vais vous présenter des nouvelles cartes
et quel est le point commun entre ces
six truc qu'on aime bien faire
premier truc manger du job dans la rue
on aime bien faire ça faire des uv en
cabine
on aime bien faire ça surtout francs de
fonds et bronzé frère c'est chelou jouer
à la console l'a10 on aime bien faire ça
regarder le dessin animé de pokémon on
aime bien faire ça mettre un casque
quand on est une femme
les femmes bien mettre des casques
ok changer une ampoule soi même on
allait bien faire ça alors là si vous la
trouvez ces cinq points c'est le ramadan
quel est ce que ça c'est des choses que
tu faire pendant le ramadan toi je vais
tout faire pour moi moi je viendrai de
voir quand tu seras là mais c'était une
personne n'est pas prendre de points le
point commun entre tout ça ce sont des
actions qu'on a le droit de faire en
france mais qu'on n'a pas le droit de
faire à l'étranger par exemple manger du
chewing-gum dans la rue c'est interdit à
singapour ah bon faire des uv en cabine
c'est interdit au brésil un jouer à la
console la nuit c'est interdit en corée
du sud
regarder le dessin animé des pokémon
c'est interdit en turquie m inquiète
quand on est une femme
c'est interdit en en had quoi oui et
changer une ampoule tout seul c'est
interdit en d'australie qu'est ce que on
arrête l'émission 100 foot une ambiance
[Rires]
et ben du coup comme il ya eu deux
points pour personne nous allons tout de
suite passer à la distribution du jeu de
la dernière partie de france je vais
tout le cui goulette quatre cartes ici
avec les nouvelles thématiques les
chewing gum les ceci je distribue
maintenant même pas comme réserve à
combien de fois on est une de l'indiana
4 est ce qu'on est prêt un deux trois
allez on y va fait partie de quatre
cartes identiques c'est bien franck
l'inventeur du high five faire des uv
c'est interdit elle sera appelée what u
pour habiller de jeu un peu calé nom de
cet acteur marcel marcel martin rondeau
on y va intrinsec attendait stop tu
disais que je ne sais pas ce qui se
passe je crois tu me inquiète tu viens
de dire qu'elle aime donc ça veut dire
qu'il aurait quatre cartes parce que je
peux voir tes 4,8 riant je peux voir les
deux autres qu'il est là il n'a pas de
coeur
enfin tu voulais dire contre 15 ça fait
donc ma quelques ratés dont un point
pour enoch et mijoux même temps mais
nous il était vrai mais si vous l'avez
du rebelle ton nom des victimes sans
même temps que les mais nous on avait
vraiment calé à la régie jamel il a dit
un ken ce qu'il n'avait pas prévu d'y
rentrer quand on a entendu c'est qu'elle
soit accordée merci
à
on n'a pas besoin de vous cacher vous
maintenant on faisait place à la grande
finale les vainqueurs
je rappelle que pour la première fois
dans kent ça n'est jamais arrivé mais
les deux perdants qui devrait être assis
là bas et sont partis ces deux personnes
très mal élevé
oui mais c'est franck gastambide hakim
djemilli sont très mauvais joueur et que
se sont barrés c'est la première fois
qu'on vit ça hakim j'ai mis 10 francs
question oui bonjour c'est franck tu
m'entendras rien ouais je t'entends même
là tout le monde à terre ouais ok bah
laissez moi finir cusset normalement
j'ai rien à dire de gentil alors cote
d'amour je vais vous poser dix questions
à chacun dise je vous poser les mêmes
questions au premier vélique poser les
questions sans limite de temps il pourra
répondre il faut répondre en pensant à
ce que va répondre l'autre savoir qu'il
est connecté d'accord si vous gagnez
gaza pour vous c'est carré c'est or
massif 44 millions
si vous ne gagnez pas si vous gagnez pas
ben voila tu vois quand on y voit là si
vous gagnez pas vous pouvez choisir un
cadeau d'adieu
vous pouvez choisir un cadeau là dedans
fait des cadeaux tiens regarde je te je
vous offre
c'est un passage piéton portable ne
tarit pas traverser la route patron de
voitures qui pose sa patte
si tu fais ok c'est hugues à 44 millions
on est prêt tu es plus que sensible au
stress qui lui tient - le stress entre
vous deux ah ouais comment rester
insensible docu reste et toi tu va
m'accompagner là bas je remettrai oui tu
vas mettre un casque sur les oreilles
entier afin de ne pas entendre ses
réponses parti tu as fatoumata qui
t'attend et qui va te mettre un déficit
est prête à tout autant ok c'est parti
c'est parti suprême ntm ou suprême de
poulet
t'as ton temps tu réfléchis et tu penses
à ce que lui va répondre suprême de
poulet
si tu étais claude françois tu serais
plutôt ça s'en va et ça revient
ça revient ça revient tu es plus souvent
en pl cas où en pls position latérale de
supposer qu'un tel est le cas on appelle
car l'abeille carton que tu préfères
contre le moc pas de ta mère ou qu'on se
moque pas de tes vêtements qu'on se bat
pas de mes vêtements
mais c'est parce que je sais qu'il va
dire ça c'est ça la complicité c'est à
dire sans les deux losers de tout à
l'heure la qui sont barrées il n'avait
pas ça à choisir tu préfères être king
l'eau ou melania trump ce n'est pas bon
bingo c'est une meuf delapierre réalité
avec un gros uc melania trump chez
9 2 3 & banking glauque himblot d'accord
tablettes de chocolat sur le ventre ont
dans le ventre dans le ventre ok burnout
ou burn février bonne série oui je leur
ai prises aussi le plus indispensable
dans ta vie aujourd'hui un bon cv ou un
bon filtre instagram bon filtre
instagram l'avenir c'était mieux avant
ou le passé ce sera pire demain
là j'avais quatre heures
je la refais parce que même moi je ne
sais pas car tu es là l'avenir
ouais c'était mieux avant ou le passé ce
sera pire demain
vas-y aux pays frères mais j'ai toujours
pas compris le passé ça sera pire demain
mais j'aime bien et attention jeu de
mots je veux du rire c'est musique
classique vivaldi ou vive lidl leader
[Applaudissements]
non c'est vrai oui mais mais c'est pas
possible
abbas il a dit réponse identique vous
avez la même connerie ça va 5 m
messieurs s'il vous plaît la musique
était incroyable c'est comme si c'était
chaud je ne sais pas c'était du dialogue
était un peu figées en gt1 c'est vrai
ouais on a droit de l'aider non correct
et asseoir toi parce que j'ai peur que
tu triches tu as l'air honnête est sympa
mais c'est un peu là on y va et bien non
les gars tu vas voir que 30 secondes
pour répondre et nantes
oui il a répondu pour les dix questions
oui mon frère on est prêt vas-y mich
on lance le chrono j'ai la pression des
chemises sales toile en asie
quarante mille balles en jeu rien pour
les assos on est parti top je suis prêt
mannequin ou suprême de poulet train de
couler ses proches de poulets registre
est un thème si tu étais claude françois
tu fais attention à couper au couteau
parce que c'est leur complicité à
classer une crise chauriens maintenant
c'est leur complicité vous êtes en train
de piquer leur complicité il n'avait pas
répondu si la mairie bonne foulée il
avait répondu non
d'accord on reprend attention remet à
zéro j'ai aussi modem novation suprême
de poulet tulle aller pour eux parce que
c'est ce qu'il a répondu si tu attends
de l'inox
oui on est prêt je suis prêt même tm ou
suprême de poulet suprême de poulet
si tu étais claude françois tu serais
plutôt 500 mains ça revient il à 10 520
coupe et on a des mecs de sécu si on a
fait ça y'a pas un jeu qui vous
prendrait il ya que chez moi chez moi
y'a pas un jeu qui vous prendra dans la
vie on reprend le truc à zéro donc
suprême de poulet tu prennes scène ces
primes de poulets c'était claude
françois très bien où ça s'en va c'est
plutôt peine en pl cas où en pls ou bien
tu préfère qu'on ne se moque pas de ta
mère ou tes vêtements
il a dit ça doit rendre sa serbie ans
note la nasa ron banon novateur y avait
le mauvais temps je me suis non mais il
m'a bien fait il va réagir alors tu peux
faire qu'on se moque pas de la mer du
tvt manta 10 vêtements
oui il a dit que pour l'instant il avait
quatre bonnes à choisir tu préfères être
connecting l'eau s'il me thierry s'est
écrasé alors ça c'est la définition
parfaite du sun vous êtes vénère vous
êtes payés nous jouer on s'amuse on
s'éclatait génial du l'apprend est super
[Applaudissements]
alors on a choisi as tu peux attribuer
aux mines et rob ongles aux tablettes de
chocolat sur le ventre ou dans le ventre
dans le ventre burnout ou burn février
les pires dispensable dans la ville
d'aujourd'hui c'est un bon cv ou un bon
filtre instagram de série il a 10 cv
non bien entendu
il nous en manque deux de tout pays
rival si vous avez qua non est le ranger
dans le cadre au passage mais c'était
trop dur alors c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave les habits je continue de gérer à
l'avers s'est produit à trop dur on a eu
un petit problème
donc tu vas voir du coup pas de la voir
un des cadeaux voyages seront choisis
c'est là dedans pour moi mais bien
entendu pas min ça c'est pour vous
l'excès ça a l'air incroyable mais
touche pas c'est pas pour vous
bah merci à tous merci à tous j'ai fait
du bon boulot avec michou c'était
millions d'abonnés s'achète pas du tout
michal et deux jours nous avons
l'honneur et le plaisir la barre mon
frère du génie de sorties nature des
biens authentiques ou bravo
on voit que vous dis merci à tous
à bientôt pour quelques chez vous s'il
allait tous nous tiens
[Musique]